hallo wir sind heute an der hebelschule
in den macht wenn wir zeigen euch welche
unserer schule in der freizeit spielen
wir auf tischtennis tiw matthias ab wir
sind in dem tool nicolai und martin
spielen
die gruppe spielt rundlauf beim rundlauf
läuft man um die tischtennisplatte herum
es gibt nicht genug schläger deshalb
kann man auch mit der hand oder einem
buch spielen
wir sind in der sporthalle
das ist ein trampolin villa machen
saltos auf dem trampolin
[Applaus]
diese schule ist ein internat
das heißt die schüler übernachten auch
in der schule
das ist unser haus wir zeigen euch jetzt
wo wir wohnen
das ist unser zimmer wir haben einen
schreibtisch und zeit werden
das ist unser küken die mission noch
abwaschen
das ist unser traum das ist unsere
deutschen es in der klasse haben alle
schüler laptops genutzt ihr kein papier
nein in dieser schule ist alles digital
und wie schreibt ihr eure lässt auf dem
computer als schüler kann man sich hier
einen computer von der schule leyen
annette wo liegt diese schule die schule
liegt in use mende und wurde am ende das
ist an der ostküste schottlands in
dänemark und was ist das besondere an
dieser schule
das ist ein internat also die schule
übernachten hier wohnen und wir sind im
spot spezialisiert das ist unser
aufenthaltsraum
das ist unser kicker und zwei schule ist
eine sportschule
das sind unsere pokale das ist unsere
spiele ecke hier spielen die schüler
playstation
[Musik]
[Applaus]